hey i'm ryan right i'm gerry today we're
checking out the trailer for the perfect
guy
no can you not when the title of the
movie is the perfect guy sounds perfect
to me I mean I don't know about you but
well I thought was gonna be a rom-com
but then I read the plot description I
haven't seen the trailer but I read the
plot and it was like twisted yeah um you
know anything with positivity in the
title means the exact no oh yeah it's
got that slash I'm just not ready I
can't wait for you anymore I don't know
you I don't either he is perfect so far
three reasons why I shouldn't buy your
drink I'm sorry I'm late you look you my
still standing here
walk away walk away I looked over and
looked like you needed a little help
same die like the man in your life that
made more see right like a diamond it
shouldn't be so hard it's like
nice to meet you
you're gonna come with me where to my
parents for the fourth I have these two
front row tickets to the Giants game and
I was wondering if you think it's so
much do you mind if I take a picture of
this car maybe ask my boyfriend when he
gets out it was like a sweet wine you
know I never hurt you right
do i I think I jump into things
sometimes how about we start over
I can't believe us here he's out there
he's watching Betty know what out this
morning to your account
recount can't you see I've been set up
you think you got a second shot
it doesn't want anything to do with you
probably remembering the sex right now
with this mug little sis face
so you can't protect me I'm doing
everything I can within the law I want
my life back
he's everywhere this looks like a better
version of that Tyler Perry movie
obsessed yeah this looks like a better
version of a lot of movies yeah dude I
was actually rather impressed with that
trailer yeah even though it does show
way too much looks like it shows the
entire movie it's like yeah well I'm
just wondering like okay like who is
going to maybe dial it down and who's
she gonna end up with or not I mean it's
not gonna be we're not here to talk
about the marketing okay we were to talk
about the actual oh yeah Michael Ealy
looks [ __ ] awesome in this role when
he was being mr. sincere a guy I was
like yes I only know what's gonna get
twisted because I read the plot
description and a trailer was clearly
setting that up well that was the cool
thing is like you started off with her
and Morris Chestnut and it's like oh
what if he becomes crazy and it's like
oh no she meets this guy now what's
going on yeah exactly
I love the dynamics of everything the
relationships feel very personal I like
how it's kind of messing with this
psychology of like jumping in too fast
to a relationship or get man she's on
the rebound yeah she's on the rebound so
it happens you rebound you date serial
killers yeah well I mean it's gotta be
hard to rebound from Morris Chestnut I
mean hmm
I know buff you know Morris Chestnut and
the rock could play like half-brothers I
was doing something more important okay
when he's being sincere it's believable
and then when he's being creepy guy he's
not overdoing it like just this is from
the clips from the trailer yeah but as
far as the trailers conveying it I was
like he's not overdoing the creepy part
he's not mr. grinning about everything
yeah it's like he has that sort of calm
disconnect that's really easy to miss
but when you know it's you know when you
know something's off then you can see
it's like an empty side of him like a
dark side of him that seems authentic
when he's doing it I just love how he's
not playing like mr. sinister cuz that
is that we know that is the typical role
of how he would you know I mean with a
[ __ ] smirk to this
now that we know yeah well that's true
it is just a trailer it's good that you
keep reminding me keep reminding it
doesn't look like a crappy romantic
movie either like it's not a romantic
film but there's elements of that way
like if Morris Chestnut the ex-boyfriend
I love how that they get him back
involved in it and making him that
person who's standing up for the main
character is perhaps you know they sis
what the trailers alluding to yeah and
the acting looks great like that one
intense scene at the bar when he's
choking Michael Ealy and then he says
like shut up or stop I forgot I'm
interested to see that scene play out in
full yeah yeah one thing that look it
looks good about this is the acting
looks really good most of the time these
movies look like pure [ __ ] this looks
like where they look cheesy exactly I
was like watching this and I'm like I'm
kind of creeped out actually things a
little bit understated a little more
natural anyway guys thanks for tuning in
to the real rejects you know where you
can do you can subscribe to the real
rejectors a man you could check out
reasons to Jerry si he's some movie
review channel dachshund estar bases
people off by talking in this garmen why
did that more like a Cheech Marin voice
no alright and you can follow us on
Facebook Instagram and Twitter or if we
get enough followers we can get product
placement I'll look what just happen
less work for me no benefit for you dad
hey guys love the channel humor jokes
humor jokes
I like your humor jokes and product
placement segments anyway I also want to
say hi hello to the real rejects family
veronika six dos yay sobbing gob right
over there a man Jerry you say the shots
you thanks man crazy hey guys I'm damn
sorry
brandy price Katie do BA Taylor Bradley
Ariana bah suri and more wow he does
know all them can I get a shout-out for
my kids
Sebastian and Aaron I have YouTube
channel but not that interesting
this is to the kids Sebastian and Aaron
and Aaron you guys stay strong you are
powerful children who are able to
unleash greatness in you dad this is
where you stop showing them the video
but if you happen to copy this video
kids now imagine an errand I'm telling
you here work together as brothers to
get the poonanny just now that were it's
not brotherly deep not disgusting joke
nope
don't you know you should work on is
something more whimsical like stacking
yourselves up and putting on a
trenchcoat and just like seeing how many
that is way too creative for my kind of
humor